une vieille enseigne et un décor
familier sur le boulevard saint-laurent
une devanture qui n'a pas changé depuis
50 ans qui fait partie de l'histoire de
la main la boucherie charcuterie
slovenia fondée par deux frères slovène
va disparaître sans fin où c'est parce
qu'il ya des problèmes mais les
problèmes des preuves d'amour
j'ai mis
un but ou là quelques jours de la
fermeture des tablettes sont dégarnis
reste encore quelques pots de choucroute
et de poivrons mais il y a encore
beaucoup de soucis sont et de produits
d'europe de l'est
un vieux comptoir qui en a vu des
factures avec sur le mur une page
encadré de calendrier de 1933 de
l'association débouché de montréal on
sent la tristesse ici l'atmosphère est
chargée et une dernière poignée de main
de la part d'un livreur
de vieux clients qui se souviennent pour
la soucoupe bien sûr mais aussi pour la
boucherie une boucherie exceptionnelle
issue oui
c'est très dommage oui moi je suis
arrivé d'europe à 73 j'ai découvert ce
mauvais ni parce que moi j ai ex
yougoslavie où ça j'achète ma pour la
dernière fois
qu'adviendra-t-il de ce commerce est
bien le propriétaire a refusé de nous
répondre se contentant de dire que c'est
la fin que c'est triste mais je leur
souhaite de les maires de chance et on
verra peut-être quelqu'un balle banques
qui continuent et les traditions
j'espère monsieur teixeira en tout cas
lui s'en va je me fonde ma passion
ça c'est je pense que je méritais la
sécurité c'est génial c'est déjà depuis
50 ans une retraite bien méritée
issigeac bissonnet radio canada bons
rêves